hier ist heute live herzlich willkommen
der Lehrermangel in Deutschland ist seit
Jahren als großes Problem erkannt allein
es tut sich wenig jedenfalls zu wenig
werden die Schüler im Stich gelassen und
auch die Lehrer könnte man ergänzen so
lautet heute unsere Frage die wir gerne
mit euch diskutieren wollen wie immer
gerne eure Fragen und Kommentare an
unsere E-Mail-Adresse bzw Fragen und
Kommentare an uns über Social Media
außerdem sprechen wir mit der
bildungsforscherin Dagmar Wolf von der
Robert Bosch Stiftung mit dem
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Gewerkschaft Erziehung und Wissenschaft
Andreas Keller und zuerst mit dem
ehemaligen Generalsekretär der
bundesschülerkonferenz nämlich mit Dario
Schramm hallo darüber wir haben uns auf
du geeinigt du bist Anfang 20 ich nur
unwesentlich älter also insofern passt
das ne
schönen Abend guten Abend
für morgen und Mittwoch hat die
Bundesbildungsministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger zu einem Bildungsgipfel
eingeladen soweit so gut allerdings
kommt zu diesem Gipfel von den 16
eingeladenen
landeskultusministerin und Ministerin
gerade mal 14 die allgemeine
Erwartungshaltung daher nicht besonders
hoch auch du hast ja schon einige
Erfahrungen gesammelt im Bereich
Bildungspolitik was sind deine
Erfahrungen an so einem Gipfel
oder Erwartungen ja vielleicht kann das
immer ich genau ich will nicht
korrigieren aber das ist ganz wichtig
erheblich es sind tatsächlich 14 die
nicht kommen also zwei Bildungsminister
kommen das ist einerseits aus Hamburg
und die kmk-präsidentin aus Berlin und
daran zeigt sich auch eben wieder wie
ernst das genommen wird es ist ein
wirkliches Trauerspiel wenn Bund und
Länder zusammenarbeiten müssen und das
ist unerweigerlich seit Jahren klar dass
es sonst nicht weiter vorankommt und am
Ende eigentlich niemand miteinander
redet dann ist klar dass das Ergebnis
von so einem Gipfel eigentlich nicht
wirklich viel aussagen sein kann ja
sorry falls ich das vertauscht habe
wollte ich natürlich genauso sagen also
14 kommen nicht das war ja das
eigentlich absurde kann man dann
überhaupt noch irgendeine Erwartung an
diese Form von Veranstaltung haben du
hast es gerade schon angerissen im
Grunde ja nicht großartig es kann
eigentlich nur der Startschuss sein für
vielleicht einen weiteren Prozess der
sich daran anschließt
ja das Problem ist dass wir ja nicht
wirklich Zeit haben es ist ja nicht so
dass wir in der Zukunft sehen dass wir
eventuell in die Probleme mit
Lehrermangel mit fehlender
Digitalisierung mit schlechten Schulen
kommen sondern das ist ja seit Jahren
klar also dieses Problem ist ja brennend
und deswegen ist es mehr als nur fatal
so zu tun als warten wir jetzt mal ab
vielleicht kommt was aus diesem Gipfel
raus sondern die Erwartungshaltung ist
klar ich finde die Bildungslandschaft
muss oder erwartet dringend dass endlich
mal an einen Tisch gekommen wird und er
wartet dann natürlich auch klare Ansagen
und das kann eigentlich nicht sein dass
2023 Sohn gibt Gipfel stattfindet und
eigentlich nicht wirklich jemand kommt
du hast über deine Schulzeit die
natürlich auch stark von der
corona-pandemie geprägt war da bist du
auch bekannt geworden was auch schon bei
uns im Stream du hast darüber ein Buch
geschrieben darin blickst du aber auch
auf die allgemeinen sozusagen
strukturellen Probleme der Schulzeit
zurück was hatte ich da wenn es auf den
Punkt bringen müsstest am meisten
gestört
ich glaube dass wir in einem System
Bildung aktuell voranbringen dass seit
Jahrzehnten sich nicht mehr verändert
hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten haben
sich so viele Probleme egal ob das die
Maronen Schulen sind ob es die fehlende
Digitalisierung ist ob es vor allem aber
auch die ja fehlende Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer sind das sind Probleme die haben
sich so angehäuft und irgendwann hat man
dann aufgehört diese Dinge anzupacken
weil man meiner Meinung nach diese Sorge
oder gar nicht mehr wusste wo fangen wir
hier eigentlich an und das ist ein ganz
erhebliches Problem was uns gerade auf
die Füße fällt weil wir immer noch
Bildung in einem Land machen oder
Bildung eben nicht so ganz Umsetzen in
diesem Land wie es sein müsste denn und
das haben wir ja auch durch den Krieg
jetzt im letzten Jahr gesehen das Gut in
diesem Land ist sind kluge Köpfe und das
können wir nicht fördern wenn wir eine
bildungsnah oder wenn wir die Bildung in
diesem Land nicht entsprechend fördern
für viele Lehrerinnen und Lehrer ist die
Situation natürlich auch nicht
zufriedenstellend auch für die
Schulleiter im übrigen oft nicht hören
wir mal rein was dort die Praxis aus den
letzten Monaten so zurück meldet
ungefähr gibt es ein riesige Notstand
während bei mir 14 Lehrkräfte die ich
nicht hätte und ich mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht durch gut
ausgebildet und normale Lehrkräfte
abdecken könnte und das werden die
Riesen Lücken richtige ausgebildete
Physik Lehrkräfte zu bekommen ist im
Prinzip unmöglich weil dort auf dem
Markt einfach gar keiner mehr ist und ja
wir sind dieses Jahr wirklich das erste
Mal in einer Situation wo wir einfach
nicht anbieten können
also teilweise das Fachunterricht gar
nicht angeboten werden kann im ersten
O-Ton ging es um die
quereinsteigerkammer nachher auch noch
drauf auch mit den anderen
Gesprächspartnern aber bleiben wir noch
mal bei dem Unterrichtsausfall wie
gesagt auch in bestimmten Fächern gar
kein Unterricht mehr möglich wie waren
deine Erfahrungen was dieses Thema
angeht
wir sehen den letzten Jahren
Unterrichtsausfall häufen sich immer
mehr wir haben teilweise Klassen die
Stunden vor dem eigentlichen Ende nach
Hause gehen und das Problem ist
eigentlich auch dass wir eben nichts
dafür tun Lehrerinnen und Lehrer zu
entlasten weil die gerade durch die
corona-zeit enorm unter Druck stehen
auch einfach an ihre Grenzen gekommen
sind oder schon weit drüber wir erleben
viele Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die
mittlerweile eben Stunde reduziert haben
und die Bundesbildungsministerin hat ja
heute den Vorschlag gemacht dass man
eben toplehrer jetzt besser bezahlt oder
mit Prämien überschüttet das suggeriert
natürlich den Eindruck dass die Lehrer
jetzt noch nicht 110% geben das möchte
ich die möchte ich ganz klar entgegen
sprechen und ich glaube dass wir schauen
müssen wie entlasten wir Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer und vor allem wie können wir es
eigentlich schaffen das Lehrer wieder
zum Kerngeschäft kommen nämlich eben
inhaltevermitteln und tatsächlich Lehren
denn aktuell gerade auch natürlich
bedingt durch die letzten Jahre ist der
Fokus auf ganz vielen Dingen aber nicht
auf unterwegs auch das wird gleich noch
mal Thema sein bei uns in der Sendung
nehmen wir mal eine Stimme rein von
quantus Fanclub über Youtube die
vorhandenen und die Jüngeren kriegen oft
nach mit dem Referendariat keine Stelle
wenn man nicht gerade
Grundschullehramt studiert hat oder
Mangelfächer Dirk schienemann schreibt
uns über Facebook ja das Problem gibt es
schon länger wer die Lehrkräfte in den
Ferien sogar entlässt und Kosten zu
sparen der spart halt falsch auch auf
diesen Punkt werden wir gleich noch mal
eingehen aber wie sehr hattest du Dario
während deiner Schulzeit den Eindruck
dass die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer selbst
überfordert sind mit der Situation auch
mit dem was sie zu leisten haben
angesichts der vielfältigen
Herausforderungen
wir hatten die corona-pandemie jetzt
oder was erst jetzt wir haben eigentlich
seit Jahren auch schon die Frage der
Digitalisierung und da ist es natürlich
eben wichtig auch Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
vorzubilden also wir können ja nicht
erwarten dass diese Menschen das alles
sozusagen learning by doing zu Hause
sich beibringen und da mangelt es vor
allem an Fortbildung entstehtigen
Fortbildungen um entsprechend diese
Fachkräfte auch zu schulen und ich
glaube dass das der ganz wichtige Punkt
ist wir müssen schauen dass man
sozusagen ja die Fortbildungen ausbaut
dass man Weiterbildungen ausbaut damit
man dem auch entgegen springt weil die
Herausforderung die Lehrerinnen und
Lehrern aktuell haben die sind enorm und
vielleicht das noch als letzten Satz es
ist eigentlich absurd dass wir in den
nächsten Jahren
100.000 fehlenden Lehrerstellen haben
immer noch enorm hohe NCS haben es ist
immer noch enorm schwierig auf Lehramt
zu studieren und das sind einfach Dinge
die nicht miteinander zu vereinbaren
sind und wir müssen eigentlich schauen
dass wir so viele junge Leute die auch
Lust auf Lehramt haben dort eben
hineinbringen können letzte Frage von
mir an Dich was machst du heute was
treibt dich um willst du vielleicht auch
mal selber Lehrer werden oder
liegt das eher fern
ich komme aus einer Lehrerfamilie mein
Opa ist Lehrer meine Mutter ist Lehrerin
und genau deswegen weiß ich was für ein
unfassbar ja anstrengender Job das ist
und ja ich glaube nicht dass ich in
einem Klassenraum irgendwann als Lehrer
stehen werde
nachvollziehbar angesichts der
momentanen Probleme aber wie gesagt
vielleicht wird sich daran ja auch noch
was tun wir werden dieses Thema
jedenfalls jetzt weiter ausführlich
besprechen vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung und Stellungnahmen Dario
Schramm war das für uns und er war
früher Vorsitzender oder man sagt
Generalsekretär der
bundesschülerkonferenz schlimmer Titel
gut den hast du jetzt abgelegt alles
Gute für deinen weiteren Lebensweg danke
schön dass du heute Abend bei uns warst
sehr gerne wir sprechen in einer Minute
mit dem stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der Lehrer Gewerkschaft GEW wollen uns
aber vorher noch mal ein paar Zahlen
anschauen die tatsächlich vor Augen
führen wie die Probleme an deutschen
Schulen derzeit sind Christian Volk
macht das
bundesweit melden die Länder mehr als
12.000 unbesetzte Lehrerstellen
allerdings ist der Mangel sehr
unterschiedlich verteilt die meisten
Lehrer fehlen in Nordrhein-Westfalen
mehr als 8.000 Stellen sind dort
unbesetzt andere Länder wie Hessen
Rheinland-Pfalz oder Bayern melden keine
einzige unbesetzte Stelle Gewerkschaften
kritisieren diese Zahlen aber als schön
gerechnet laut ihren Schätzungen fehlen
in Deutschland wohl mindestens 20.000
Lehrkräfte einer der Gründe die Zahl der
Lehramt Absolventen geht zurück sie sang
zwischen 2011 und 2021 von
33.500 auf
28.900 ein Minus von fast 14 Prozent
gleichzeitig steigt die Zahl der
Geburten von 2011 bis 2016 von 663
000 auf 792.000 an den Grundschulen
macht sich das seit ein paar Jahren
bemerkbar an den weiterführenden Schulen
kommt der Zuwachs gerade an hinzu kommen
mehr als 200.000 geflüchtete Kinder und
Jugendliche aus der Ukraine auch deshalb
gab es im vergangenen Jahr so viele
Erstklässler wie seit 17 Jahren nicht
mehr
und wir sprechen mit dem
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Gewerkschaft Erziehung und Wissenschaft
Andreas Keller einen schönen guten Abend
Herr Keller schönen guten Abend Herr
Wehrmann ja wir haben gerade einige
Zahlen gehört die das Problem
verdeutlichten es gibt also ein
erheblichen Lehrermangel an den Schulen
der obendrein ja auch nicht wirklich
überraschend konnte wie sehen Sie die
gegenwärtige Situation ja das waren
interessante Zahlen und vor allem muss
man dazu ja noch eins sagen dass ist ja
erst der Anfang also die Stellen die
jetzt im Moment nicht besetzt sind
wurden genannt mit 30.000 nach unseren
Informationen aber wir rechnen damit und
da gibt es verschiedene Studien die
zeigen dass wir bis 2035 mehrere
hunderttausend Lehrerin und Lehrer haben
bzw nicht haben also einen Mangel in
dieser Größenordnung wir als
gewannen eigentlich seit Jahren davor
die Kultusministerkonferenz hat die
Zahlen immer runtergerechnet oder wollte
sie den sie unter tuneln und jetzt haben
wir die Misere und da müssen wir
dringend gegen Maßnahmen ergreifen
wir sprechen gleich noch mal über den
Bildungsgipfel der wird von unserem User
danf als bildungshügelchen bezeichnet
wenn überhaupt bei uns brennt die Hütte
renne zeitweise nur noch zwischen
mehreren Klassen hin und her richtiger
Unterricht ist dann kaum noch möglich
Schüler Aufbewahrung schreibt er uns
sprechen wir über die Veranstaltung die
morgen und übermorgen stattfindet wir
hatten gerade schon davon nur 14 bzw
andersrum 14 der 16 Kultusminister haben
abgesagt wie stehen Sie zu dieser
Veranstaltung und was kann sie überhaupt
bringen
also unsere Vorsitzende Maike Finnern
wird auch morgen mit diskutieren aber in
der Tat hätten wir uns eigentlich einen
größeren Wurf gewünscht und bei allem
Respekt gegenüber der
Bundesbildungsministerin vielleicht
müsste es so ein Thema wie ein
Bildungsgipfel damit es wirklich einen
Gipfel wird und nicht nur ein Hügel oder
eine eine Versammlung an der Talstation
müsste so ein Gipfel zur Chefinnen und
Chefsache werden also eigentlich sehe
ich hier den Bundeskanzler und die
regierungschefininnen und
Regierungschefs gefragt einen Gipfel
einzuberufen und anderen auch alle
Akteure Schülerinnen Vertretungen
Gewerkschaften an einem Tisch zu holen
denn es ist ein großes Problem und da
braucht es eine gemeinsame Anstrengung
wir können uns gerade noch mal das habe
ich von ihrer sozusagen Homepage
geklappt bzw man kann sich das da
einfach anschauen der ist also eine
Karte abgebildet so schlimm ist der
Lehrkräfte mal in Deutschland da gibt es
also durchaus Unterschiede dunkelrot
oder je dunkler umso schlechter ist die
Situation man sieht hier vor allem in
den östlichen Bundesländern gibt es ein
Problem auch
in Berlin
inwiefern spielt hier die Tatsache dass
Bildungspolitik Ländersache ist eine
Rolle und verschärft diese Tatsache das
Problem oder ist dieser Umstand eher
hilfreich was würden Sie sagen in der
Tat war ja auf dieser Karte zu sehen es
gibt dunkelrot und hellrot aber kein
Grün das heißt wir haben bundesweit ein
Problem und der Föderalismus ist
natürlich in der Tat ein Teil des
Problems denn eigentlich wäre jetzt auch
der Bund gefragt hier
die Länder zu unterstützen Lehrkräfte
besser auszubilden also der Bund hat
bestimmte Möglichkeiten so legt er zum
Beispiel eine Qualitätsoffensive
Lehrerbildung auf oder es gibt auch
einen zukunftsvertragsstudium und Lehre
stärken mit dem zusätzlichen
Studienplätze geschaffen werden aber der
Bund hat versäumt über diese praktikte
gezielte Anreize zu setzen dass die
Länder auch wirklich ausreichend
stutenplätze zur Verfügung stellen das
ist ein Problem dass wir in vielen
Ländern
studieren willige Studienberechtigte
haben die keinen Studienplatz kriegen
zum Beispiel im Grundschullehramt und
hier wäre eigentlich der Bund gefragt
auf Bundesebene entsprechende Anreize zu
setzen dazu kommt dann noch ein anderes
Problem dass ich die Länder gegenseitig
die AbsolventInnen Absolventen abjagen
weil sie selbst unter Bedarf ausbilden
und das kann natürlich auch keine Lösung
sein ja das sie spielen auch an auf den
Vorschuss unter anderem das bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten der gesagt hat sie
wollen jetzt eben auch aus anderen
Bundesländern
lehrerkandidaten und Kandidatinnen nach
Bayern locken aber das ist in ganz
interessanter Punkt den sie da auch noch
angesprochen haben das ist darum geht
dass es auch einfach zu wenig
Ausbildungsplätze gibt wie kann das denn
eigentlich sein warum gibt es zu wenige
ja also tatsächlich ist es so dass
eigentlich jedes einzelne Bundesland
weniger Lehrerinnen und lehrerausbildet
als eigentlich der Bedarf erfordern
würde und das hängt letztlich damit
zusammen das war die Länder die
Hochschule finanzieren
aber zu wenig über Zielvereinbarung oder
auch über gesetzliche Vorgaben steuern
also Vorgaben machen das tatsächlich
Studienplätze bereitgestellt werden und
an den Hochschulen ist die Lehrerbildung
häufig so was wieder fünf wie das fünfte
Rad am Wagen das steht also nicht im
Mittelpunkt damit kann man keine mehr
Riten häufig in der Forschung verdienen
und ein sinnvoller Ansatz wäre zu sagen
dass die Länder im Idealfall alle Länder
aber alle Länder die dazu bereit sind
sich in einem Staatsvertrag dazu
verpflichten
ausreichend Studienplätze zur Verfügung
zu stellen damit eben diese
Kannibalisierung ein Land wird beim
anderen die Lehrkräfte ab dann ein Ende
hat Alexander Handel schreibt uns über
Youtube Fakten aus dem angeblich voll
versorgten Hessen selbst am Gymnasium
fallen ständig Stunden aus AGs werden
gekürzt kaum Zeit für Exkursionen
geschweige denn LK Weiterbildung können
wir noch mal auf einen anderen Punkt zu
sprechen die ständige wissenschaftliche
Kommission SWK heißt dies ist ein
Berater Premium der
Kultusministerkonferenz die hatte im
Januar bereits vorgeschlagen die
Möglichkeiten der Teilzeitarbeit zu
begrenzen für Lehrerinnen und Lehrer um
somit mehr Kapazitäten bei den
Lehrkräften zu mobilisieren dagegen gab
es große Proteste von Seiten der
Gewerkschaft aber man könnte jetzt ja
denken zunächst mal der Vorschlag ist ja
einleuchtend warum ist er das nicht naja
dieser Vorschlag der SWK ist eigentlich
ein gutes Beispiel dafür wie man den
Teufel mit dem Bild austreibt oder
vielleicht sogar die Situation
verschlimmern könnte ein Problem des
lehrkräftemangels ist ja dass der Beruf
nicht mehr so attraktiv ist weil die
Bedingungen spätestens seit Corona
wissen das auch alle sehr dramatisch
sind es ist eine Überlastung durch den
Mangel auch bedingt gegeben und von
daher wäre es eigentlich notwendig den
Beruf attraktiv zu machen die
Betreuungsrelationen zu verbessern und
wenn nun die SWK hier geht und
feststellt naja wir haben hier so viele
Zeit Teilzeitbeschäftigte wir müssen die
Teilzeitquoten reduzieren wir müssen die
Stunden erhöhen wir müssen die
Altersgrenzen anheben dann würden ja die
Bedingungen gerade noch verschlechtert
und womöglich weitere Lehrkräfte oder
bzw potenzielle Lehrkräfte abgeschreckt
diesen Beruf zu ergreifen und das ist
genau das Gegenteil was wir brauchen wir
müssen die Bedingungen verbessern wir
müssen die Lehrkräfte entlasten zum
Beispiel durch IT-Fachkräfte durch
Verwaltungskräfte in
multiprofessionellen Teams auch durch
Sozialpädagogin Pädagogen durch
SchulpsychologInnen dann könnten sich
die Lehrkräfte auf ihre kernarbeit guten
Unterricht zu machen konzentrieren
Symbole aller Studentinnen und Studenten
und sie weiter zu belasten das wird
genau das Gegenteil für herbeiführen wir
haben verstehen
uns über Youtube gibt es
lehramtsempfehlungen nach zukünftigen
Bedarf also dahinter steckt ja auch die
Frage nicht in allen Fächern sozusagen
ist der Bedarf gleich groß kann man
heute schon sagen Leute interessiert
euch nach Möglichkeit für diese oder
jene Fächer
naja es gibt eigentlich mittlerweile in
fast allen Fächern und Mangel bekannt
ist dass in den mintfächern also in
Naturwissenschaften insbesondere noch
ein größerer Mangel ist aber in Kürze
werden wir flächendeckenden Mangel haben
ich würde
Studienberechtigten
schulabsolventinnen raten erstmal nach
ihren Neigungen Interessen zu gehen und
nicht nur auf den Arbeitsmarkt zu
schielen denn wir wollen ja dass die
Leute die dann in die Schulen gehen auch
in motiviert sind und einen guten Job
machen und deswegen ist ist man da
glaube ich am besten beraten ihre
Gewerkschaft hat 15 Forderungen bzw
Vorschläge gemacht das können wir uns
auch gerade noch mal anschauen wie man
dem Lehrkräfte Mangel begegnen sollte
kann man sich auch noch mal on Detail
anschauen auf ihrer Website also wir
wollen jetzt nicht alle aufzählen alle
15 aber vielleicht wenn sie noch mal die
wichtigsten Anliegen der GEW vortragen
würden um die Situation zu verbessern
was was müsste sie tun na wir haben da
verschiedene Stoßrichtungen also ein
zentrales Motiv ist wirklich den Beruf
auch attraktiver zu machen um Gebäude zu
begeistern dieses Studienfach zu machen
aber vor allem auch dafür zu sorgen dass
die Leute nicht ausgebrannt den Battle
hinschmeißen und rausgehen dazu gehört
die schon angesprochene Entlastung durch
andere Berufsgruppen dazu gehört aber
auch eine bessere Bezahlung und der
Lehrkräfte die im Moment an Grundschulen
oder auch teilweise in der Sekundarstufe
zwar eins noch deutlich schlechter
bezahlt werden das ist ein Ansatz der
andere Ansatz ist aber auch tatsächlich
die Ausbildungssituation zu verbessern
mehr Studienplätze zu schaffen
Studienabbrecherquoten zu reduzieren wir
haben hohe Studienabbruch geworden wir
brauchen bessere Betreuungsrelationen an
den Hochschulen aber auch im
Vorbereitungsdienst im Referendariat
ausreichend Plätze und dort auch eine
Bezahlung der über den mindestlohnniveau
liegt heute ist es ja so dass
Referendarin Referendare unter dem
mindestlohnniveau als dumping Lehrkräfte
eingesetzt werden es ist auch noch mal
eine schwierige Durststrecke also mit
dem Studium nach fünf Jahren ist man
noch nicht Ziel sondern muss das
Referendariat absolvieren und das alles
sorgt dafür dass dieser Studien dass
dieser Arbeitsplatz nicht attraktiv
genug ist und darum müssen die
Bedingungen verbessert werden und wie
gesagt die Länder müssen sich
verpflichten hier eine gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung zu machen Idealfall mit
Unterstützung des Bundes ist natürlich
auch eine finanzielle Frage die sie da
ansprechen und da fragt uns unsere
Userin Anker HRO große Unternehmen
müssen doch auch ein Interesse an
gebildeten Nachwuchs haben wo sind hier
die benötigten Mittel und das Interesse
also besteht sozusagen die Möglichkeit
die Wirtschaft da auch heranzuziehen um
die Situation an Schulen zu verbessern
also in der Tat ist es so dass die
gesamte Gesellschaft und auch die
Wirtschaften großes Interesse haben
müsste daran dass die Schülerinnen und
Schüler von ausgebildeten Lehrkräften
und nicht von Gewehr und
Seiteneinsteigern oder womöglich gar
nicht unterrichtet werden oder
Unterricht ausfällt mancherorts wird das
schon die vier Tage Woche diskutiert und
deswegen müsste auch die Wirtschaften
Interesse daran haben der Antwort der
GEW ist ja das kostet Geld und der Staat
muss dann auch den Willen haben durch
eine vernünftige Besteuerung durch den
Steuersystem dafür zu sorgen dass dann
auch tatsächlich die Schulen besser
finanziert werden ausreichend
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer ausgebildet
werden der Beruf attraktiv wird das ist
eine Entscheidung die der Staat treffen
muss und wo dann natürlich dann auch die
Wirtschaft entsprechend über Steuern
ihren Beitrag leisten muss
Andreas Keller war der stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Gewerkschaft Erziehung
und Wissenschaft vielen Dank und einen
schönen Abend nach Berlin danke schön
vielleicht noch einen Kommentar von der
Maxim Kloster uns hat er erreicht über
Youtube eigentlich müssten alle
Bildungsminister die abwesend bei dieser
Veranstaltung sind auch abgewählt werden
ist ganz klar Arbeitsverweigerung so
jedenfalls seine Meinung das Problem des
Lehrermangels ist übrigens nicht neu
sondern Jahrzehnte alt zum Beweis haben
wir mal unseren Archiv gekramt und
diesen Beitrag von
1990 gefunden es sind nicht nur die
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer die auf die
Straße gehen jetzt sind es auch die
Schülerinnen und Schüler die gegen den
ständigen unterrichtshaushalt
demonstrieren und protestieren
Bilder aus dem letzten Schuljahren an
vielen Orten fanden Protestaktionen
statt streikt den Schüler und
Schülerinnen äußerten Eltern ihren Unmut
mit Luftballons wurde überall die
gleiche Forderung verbreitet mehr Lehrer
und Lehrerinnen damit weniger Unterricht
ausfällt
[Applaus]
tja also das Problem beschäftigt die
Politik schon lange und wir fragen die
bildungsforscherin Dagmar Wolf von der
Robert Bosch Stiftung warum das so ist
erstmal einen schönen guten Abend vor
Wolf hallo guten Abend ja wir haben
sogar Beiträge aus den 70ern gefunden in
unserem Archiv in denen das Problem auch
schon auftauchte warum fällt es der
Politik dann offenbar so schwer auf die
er vermeintlich klar erkennbaren Geburts
Entwicklungen mit dem entsprechenden
lehrerangebot zu reagieren
ja das ist eine Frage die ich Ihnen
leider auch nicht beantworten kann wir
haben das hat ja Herr Keller auch schon
sehr deutlich dargestellt wir haben
Bedarfs Analysen und auch Prognosen von
renommierten Bildungsforschern Klaus
Klemm ist da einer der ganz vorne ist
der uns seit Jahren
prognostiziert dass das was jetzt da ist
kommen wird diese Zahlen sind bekannt
sie waren allerdings nie deckungsgleich
mit den Zahlen die die einzelnen
Bundesländer erhoben haben da wurden
Zahlen tatsächlich auch geschönt es
wurden zum Teil
falsche Zahlen herangezogen um Bedarfe
zu prognostizieren und dementsprechend
wurde auch nicht wirklich genügend
ausgebildet auch das hat Herr Keller
sehr schön dargestellt die Bundesländer
bilden lange nicht so viel aus wie sie
am Ende brauchen und das ist
letztendlich die Misere in dem momentan
sind
ein Problem das kam ja für ihn im
Gespräch mit Herrn Keller auch schon zum
Tragen wie kann es denn eigentlich sein
dass angesichts einer leerer Knappheit
die sich wie gesagt auch schon seit
Jahren im Prinzip abzeichnet für
anstehende selbst Grundschullehrerin und
Lehrer zum Beispiel im Jahr 2017/18
immer noch ein relativ hoher Numerus
Clausus teilweise von 1,7 bestanden hat
wie es ihre Erklärung darauf naja wie
das zustande kommt das relativ einfach
der Numerus clauses orientiert sich an
den
Bewerberzahlen und dann am Ende an den
zur Verfügung stehenden Plätzen und wenn
die zu gering sind dann ist es natürlich
am Ende auch so dass weniger Studierende
als sich eigentlich interessieren würden
für dieses Studium zugelassen werden
also es ist eine Frage des fehlenden
Angebots und der dann im Vergleich zu
hohen Nachfrage
genau jetzt ist es so dass einzelne
Bundesländer nachgesteuert haben das
aber zum Teil so kurzfristig kam das
entsprechend eben die Studienplätze in
diesem Jahr auch nicht wird oder im
letzten Jahr zum Herbst nicht besetzt
werden konnten aber dementsprechend war
eben auch schon die Studienwahl bei
vielen abgeschlossen über Youtube fragt
uns Camel ohne wir sollten einfach mehr
Steuern zahlen und Abgaben tätigen das
wird sicher alles lösen zumindest meine
Lust auf Arbeit vielleicht eine Lehrerin
oder Lehrer wir wissen es nicht mal
abgesehen davon dass wahrscheinlich
nicht alle zustimmen würden aber ist es
ein finanzielles Problem in erster Linie
also das was wir wissen ist dass es
weniger ein finanzielles Problem ist die
finanziellen Anreize sind eigentlich da
der lehrerberufe ist
in Deutschland im europäischen Vergleich
gut bezahlt was natürlich ein Problem
ist dass wir immer noch unterschiedliche
bezahlungsstufen haben
Grundschullehrerinnen und Lehrer
verdienen immer noch weniger als
Gymnasiallehrer da muss man nach Steuern
das sollte man nachsteuern letztendlich
ist aber das eigentliche Problem dass
die Attraktivität des Arbeitsplatzes sie
wollen sicher auch sehr viel lieber an
einem Arbeitsplatz Arbeiten an dem die
Bedingungen gut sind sowohl räumlich wie
auch was die Ausstattung angeht und da
haben wir in den Schulen einfach einen
riesengroßen Nachholbedarf klar also das
glaube ich kann nicht bejahen und das
gilt mit Sicherheit für die allermeisten
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer the
great schreibt uns über Youtube die
Bilder der 70er bzw der 90er die wir
gezeigt haben zeigen doch perfekt das im
Grunde halt doch kein Interesse an der
Lösung des Problems besteht lieber schön
rechnen haben Sie den Eindruck dass das
Thema Bildung tatsächlich den
Stellenwert genießt der ihm zukommen
müsste eigentlich sagen doch immer alle
Politiker aller Parteien das Bildung das
allerwichtigste sei
ja wir haben natürlich schon ganz klar
die Bekenntnisse zur Bildung wenn es
aber am Ende darum geht sich wirklich
auch langfristig für Veränderungen
einzusetzen langfristig auch
Finanzierungen zu sichern sieht leider
schon wieder anders aus und das ist ja
mit eins unserer Probleme dass wir
eigentlich ein eine unterfinanziertes
System haben das sieht man an den
Schulen an dem Zustand der Schulen auch
an der Ausstattung haben wir über Jahre
einfach zu wenig investiert auch wenn
sie noch mal die frage morgen der
Bildungsgipfel eher ein Gipfelchen
welche Erwartungen haben sie an diese
Veranstaltung
ich persönlich habe jetzt nicht mehr so
wahnsinnig viele Erwartungen an diese
Veranstaltung weil wir eben er praktisch
kaum die Beteiligung der einzelnen
Länder haben Bildung ist Ländersache
dementsprechend braucht das natürlich
auch die
kultusministerinnen und Kultusminister
der Länder und da kann ich Herrn Keller
nur zustimmen wir sind in einer
Situation in der das eigentlich dann
auch zur Chefsache gemacht werden müsste
und auch dementsprechend neben dem
Bundeskanzler auch die
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder da gehört
werden sollten und ich glaube wir sind
in einer Situation in der wir einfach
auch eine sehr viel breitere Beteiligung
brauchen wenn sie es nochmal auf den
Punkt bringen müssten was muss geschehen
um den Lehrerberuf attraktiver zu machen
also ich glaube es braucht relativ viel
einmal ist es nicht damit getan jetzt
die Teilzeitquote zu reduzieren sondern
wir müssen im Grunde Anreize schaffen
dass Menschen Lehrkräfte werden dazu
gehört dass wir entsprechend Bedingungen
schaffen die so sind dass man gerne in
einer Schule arbeitet wir brauchen
multiprofessionelle Teams wir brauchen
eine gute Ausstattung auch an
verwaltungskräften und it-kräften die
Schule unterstützen das kann nicht mehr
der einzelne Lehrer oder die einzelne
Lehrerin sein die dafür eine
Anrechnungsstunde bekommt um
entsprechend den Computerraum
auszustatten und zu warten wir brauchen
aber auch auf der Länder eben in eine
koordinierte Bedarfsprognose und eine
vernünftige kapazitätenplanung und wir
brauchen vor allem auch gemeinsame
Qualitätsstandards der Länder beim
Quereinstieg ohne den werden wir dieses
Problem momentan nicht mehr in Griff
kriegen das heißt wir brauchen Menschen
die sich dafür entscheiden
aber wir brauchen auch dazu wirklich
definierte Qualitätsstandards die die
Länder übergreifend vereinbaren und dann
auch einhalten ja also Standards für
Qualität sowohl was die Quereinsteiger
angeht aber vielleicht noch ein Thema
was hier gerade aufgeworfen wird über
Youtube von Frank Fernau KI kann Sachen
künstliche Intelligenz also kann Sachen
tausendmal besser erklären als
überforderte Lehrer natürlich sind nicht
alle Lehrer überfordert das wollen wir
schärfsten zurückweisen ich weiß dass
angehende Lehrer schon KI für die Uni
arbeiten benutzen vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz zum Schluss ihre Einschätzung
zum Thema künstliche Intelligenz was
kommt da oder müsste da auf die
Schülerinnen und Schüler zu kommen
die künstliche Intelligenz wird kommen
und die ist ja auch schon da alle
Menschen reden von Chat und Schülerinnen
und Schüler benutzen das auch und ich
glaube wir müssen uns auch darüber im
Klaren sein dass wir diese Entwicklung
nicht zurückdrängen können und das ist
eigentlich die die zentrale und die
spannende Frage wie können wir Zukunft
denken und das müssen wir jetzt tun
beantworten mit Konzepten in Schulen die
einfach zum Teil 80 bis 100 Jahre alt
sind wir müssen jetzt überlegen wie muss
Schule aussehen und dazu gehört zum
Beispiel auch dass wir drüber nachdenken
ob alle Unterricht immer als
Präsenzunterricht stattfinden muss
welche digitalen Möglichkeiten gibt es
und da müssen wir weiter denken als das
was wir in der corona-zeit als wirkliche
Notfall
ein notfallunterricht erlebt haben da
geht es jetzt wirklich darum auch zu
überlegen inwieweit kann Unterricht in
Teilen digital stattfinden sicher nicht
in der Grundschule aber in einer
Oberstufe warum denn nicht warum kann
nicht an Teil des Unterrichts digital
stattfinden Schülerinnen und Schüler
lernen schon lange mit dem Internet
Schülerinnen und Schüler schauen sich
schon lange Erklärvideos an und da wird
KI ein weiteres tun dass das auch immer
stärker im Unterricht eine Rolle spielen
wird und das müssen wir einbinden und
nicht verhindern der Schulalltag also
höre ich raus wird sich verändern tut es
ja jetzt auch schon danke schön das
waren die Einschätzungen von
bildungsforscherinnen Dagmar Wolf von
der Robert Bosch Stiftung danke dass Sie
für uns zur Verfügung standen einen
schönen Abend danke sehr danke ebenso
ja ein spannendes Thema man könnte da
noch stundenlang drüber diskutieren das
soll es jetzt mal gewesen sein für heute
Abend anlässlich des Bildungsgipfels
morgen und übermorgen wir halten euch
auch darüber natürlich dann im weiteren
Programm auf dem Laufenden spätestens
bei den News im ganz normalen Fernsehen
danke schön für eure Aufmerksamkeit für
eure zahlreichen Fragen und Kommentare
wir wünschen euch einen schönen Abend
und sagen bis zum nächsten Mal macht's
gut ciao